we're late to the trends on Gregg I'm
John top 10 savage ricky gervais insults
the best host to have ever come out of
the Golden Globes a monumental staple in
comedy I adore Ricky Gervais he is so
freakin funny his stand-up surgar
interviews everything about him he's
savage he's motivated many people to be
atheists tearing down that Zod yeah it's
kind of huge where video stood well
[Music]
[Music]
of course
[Laughter]
yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
Oh Kim Cattrall was the only actors mr.
big himself Chris Noth wasn't no giant
that was respect it's gonna be a night
party and heavy drinking
Oh as charlie sheen calls it breakfast
your face didn't stop there was for the
mother of all the walking dead
congratulations to Hugh Hefner who was
getting married at the age of 84 to 24
year-old Billy Crystal Harris when she
was asked why she was marrying she said
because he lied about his age he told me
it was 94 94 and therefore had fewer
years left if that jump wasn't shocking
enough sure many said that room windy
and the next
don't worry
oh and just just don't look at it when
you touch it Jeremy Renner's comment
about Jennifer Lopez's golden globes may
have been awkward but remember what your
base had to say about Jenny from the
block
although Lopez came from humble
beginnings in the Bronx she's evolved
into one of the wealthiest women in the
business my material for Gervase she's
just Jenny from the block if the block
in question is that one on Rodeo Drive
between Cartier and Prada in a radio
station Lopez claims that she suspected
that your base might take a shot at her
during a ceremony before me introduced
her Lopez reportedly unleashed her inner
diva backstage from New York Jets often
told those jokes anyway compared to some
other celebs Lopez felt she got off easy
number three Caitlyn Jenner the 73rd
Golden Globe Awards for your - your base
returned to host the Globes with a beer
by side
heads up insults throughout this opening
monologue Jimmy sounded like a kid just
got released from timeout saying that
he'd tried yes actually it didn't take a
lot for Gervase to break his promise
diving headfirst into a Caitlyn Jenner
joke I've changed not as much as Bruce
Jenner now Caitlyn Jenner of course what
I hear she's had she became a role model
for trans people everywhere showing
great bravery in breaking down barriers
and destroying stereotypes
that's pretty sure bass rocked the boat
the first year he goes through the
Golden Globes the following year however
he officially turned the boat upside
down with this jaw-dropping joke about
Jim Carrey and Ewan McGregor starring in
I love you Philip Morris Jim Carrey and
Ewan McGregor to heterosexual actors
pretending to be gay so the
Scientologists
[Music]
[Music]
hey just mentioned supper marble
I like marble oh yes John wick mortal
kombat anime that's like everything that
the internet there's one ricky gervais
said something about the sugar tits one
that's the one that you mean you mean
this list held back on some savagery to
probably avoid a yellow dollar bill like
what I just
we can always bleep it sugar sugar
present when Ricky Gervais went up to
him and recommend what does where they
bleep it out I'd buy his lips he says
what does sugar you're sure your tits
mean and then you seem okay because the
first needs being playful at is on
writing ztc one
and they you see we like really upset
yeah you can see mouthed I don't like
masks it really you just see that rage
face that he's trying to block it with a
smile oh yeah I mean though Mel's end is
like staccato
it seems like his whole energy is
basically going to being presentable
that's funny because they did the two
back to back in this list where one was
when Malph came back to the Golden
Globes and a follow up one now looks
like he aged like eight years every
three years every two years Mel Gibson
ages ten more years yeah I know about
Mel Gibson now his beards keep changing
he'll look like a Civil War general
after all yeah I mean I know that I
prepared this list in advance and
because of the Golden Globes that were
come out over here base supposedly
hosting for the lot I really hope it's
the last time he does host that is the
best way for him to go out that
monologue that he had was as a
combination of that was raw that was
savage and thank you he said the things
that people like but more it was like he
makes really edgy roasting kind of jokes
the things he said especially about like
Apple other companies in the Harvey well
it's teaching I was in the model of the
Harvey Weinstein one but the things he
said were like so freakin honest about
your speeches being political all the
time - and yet you know like there are a
bunch of other companies that do have
the horrible business practices that
you're feeding into you know which
doesn't nullify a good political point
but it does make you think like oh okay
there's a long way to go for heretic Lee
on points I'm surprised
NBC has been cool with bringing him back
so much I mean he does wonders for the
ratings as wonders for the controversy
in the talking but he tastes such even
took a stab at the Hollywood Foreign
Press a good amount of times and his
last Golden Globes it was the best he's
ever done it was the best he's ever a
lie he's like he's great every time but
it was the best he's ever done so I
really do hope he just stand by it and
say it's a and commit to it being his
last time what he does III think it's
such a great balance for
those of you hillarious if you came back
for the oscars his next step of like I
said I'm gonna do the Golden Gloves I'm
doing the Oscars moving on them to the
Academy then he would just make fun of
the Oscars their history in such a way
that's not holding back well yeah and I
think that speaks to the side of a lot
of people that don't really care or
don't feel like the awards really
represent the taste of the populace feel
like that does bridge a gap so that you
know you're taking the piss out of the
ceremony just as much as the ceremony is
being regal and awarding people so that
level of irony like tempers things
wellthat taking the piss out of people
who take themselves so seriously this is
a form of entertainment really hyper
glorified works of fiction even if
you're doing adaptation it's still
something that is essentially a form of
entertainment and I don't think it's bad
to use your platform to talk about
important issues and he said political I
feel like he was talking specifically
about things that deal with like you
know Republicans Democrats Trump that
kind of thing some kind considering to
talk about environmental issues like
that is technically political yeah it's
like and I feel like really Gervase was
like cool with that because that's a
different kind of arena to talk about
even though does still fall into the
political landscape it's it's just that
people do you can see it they take
themselves so seriously and these award
ceremonies I feel like the light that's
been shine on them so much as of late is
how pretentious so much of it has been
to have someone like Ricky Gervais steer
to balance that out with really making
like really making fun not like
light-hearted comedy really making fun
of it and showing you guys shouldn't
take it seriously I love watching the
celeb reactions of who is all my work
for this is not on board for this the
ones you could tell are like actors and
filmmakers we do them entertainment some
might consider what we do important but
there's definitely more important things
that matter than one of this freaking
awards show is he you know yeah and I
feel like there is a certain element of
his approach especially that goes to
illuminate some of the limitations and
the narrow field that
the Foreign Press at least sometimes is
coming from in terms of who they're
nominating and choosing to award and you
know we've had controversies this year
again about you know the lack of
diversity among the nominations snubs
and all that it's interesting because I
feel like in a way I wonder what's gonna
happen because if we go back to a host
that's just jovial and just with the
program I wonder what that's gonna do to
the show because I feel like almost
having him around makes for edgy humor
but it can make the show better you know
if he brings up a particularly good
point especially about the quality of
the show or the Hollywood Foreign Press
is judgement that could have an effect
somewhere you never know but he's also
doesn't make fun of those who have one
though you didn't know like throughout
the night you know what I mean like what
I mean by that is he doesn't do what
Kanye did to Taylors ha ha
you know what I mean like you didn't
deserve that he did he doesn't insult
them for being nominated or being
represented for the work of why they're
being highlighted there today do you
know what I mean
yes ribbing the specific people but not
[ __ ] on the work that they've done
making fun of it sure he's not insulting
them in a way where he's making them
feel like they don't deserve to be there
or they don't deserve to be nominated or
anything like that
weirdly he writes a very interesting
balance because some might think he goes
too far but I think it's balanced and I
think NBC is ok with it obviously they
brought it back so many times he's a gem
it's [ __ ] Jam comedy world he's a
gentleman he really has left a unique
stamp on this Ricky Oscar's 20/20
alright guys so what's your favorite
Ricky Gervais insulted he got one I'll
leave it on the comment boxes do you
think he should host the Oscars one day
how great with that they subscribe to
watchmojo.com oh thank you so much dude
it's been a few weeks it's I've heard
from you man don't know what's happening
here you said you had an all right
Christmas snow had melted in Sweden
sorry about that buddy but it sounds
like overall you had a good Christmas I
asked you what your resolutions for the
new year are you haven't gotten back to
me I think that's because you're afraid
to get back to me without a
answer so you better have some awesome
resolutions in mind to present one of
those better be get an eight pack abs
get glute implants mmm get that bubble
button be able to benchpress 25 pounds
on each side of the bar it's a good goal
it's a good starting go yeah John's
almost there
time almost and don't work out with me
Mikhail we can spot each other it'll be
great and to also grow a mustache oh you
would look awesome with a mustache and
it'll duster that big button it's just a
human the must a huge ass